the mission of GSI is to really help
athletes optimize their performance and
their health through research and
education we work very closely with the
different parts of our area including
the product development team of gatoring
what we do here is really get the
insights from the athlete to really
drive innovation in the future this
particular test is looking at what fuels
is using so we can put those fuels back
into the body keep it up all the air
that he's inhaling and all the air that
he's exhaling is all measured from that
we can calculate how much oxygen is
using how much carbon dioxide is
producing and what do you do with this
data Oscar if we see his values we can
compare him to other athletes who do the
same sport so we can see where he is it
also helps us to estimate where he could
get to keep pushing through
we do a sweat test with athletes because
every athlete sweats differently we
applied matches to capture the sweat
public open they'll stay strong here and
then after that practice we measured
body weight again and during the
practice we measured the bottles and how
much they drank so if we put all that
information together we know exactly how
much they're sweating what they're
sweating so we know what to replace what
is this measure it measures a
combination of your peripheral vision
and your ability to respond with your
signals do I dare try go ahead okay yes
for three oh five - five - it alright so
almost not upsetting that oh yeah what
we do with GSSI globally is very
coordinated the information that we
collect from athletes worldwide all
comes together into this central
database and from there we can start to
do some of the analysis and see what
patterns and trends that we are seeing
we're just listening to athletes trying
to understand what their needs are at
the same time we also have some ideas
and there are some scientific insights
that can help us to develop products in
the initial term